I feel like your career isn't something
you pursued like you kind of fell into
it you you obviously were born in London
right correct uh-huh and your parents
weren't show business people know right
yeah your mom was a teacher and your dad
was a well an ex-soldier in a dyeing
carpets firm he was a soldier
yeah originally did he serve in a war
yeah he was in the jungle in Malaya
beating up communists was he a tough guy
well you know they always play it down
and so we don't really know real tough
guys never say hey man I'm this great
warrior or they don't tell you how many
kills they had right like of guy I know
but my grandfather was the really tough
guy
yeah he was in two world wars and he
escaped from prisoner of war camp in
Germany and that was cool when I was
growing up he used to show us all his
escape equipment and so when you grow up
with a dad who's this you know rugged
guy your grandfather so the line broke
that and then you announced you want to
be an actor and they look at you like
come here you [ __ ]
they like kind of like did they want you
to serve in the military and and yeah I
think my grandfather would have liked
that yeah I would have liked it I would
have looked so nice in the uniform was
it shameful for you to say I want to be
an actor was that a tough thing for you
to admit to they just kind of macho guys
that was never my ambition I fell into
acting right I it was meant to be a
temporary job for a year when I was 22
or something but you acted in a school
play when you were a kid I played almost
exclusively female roles it was all boys
school oh and so the pretty boys played
the female parts so who did you who did
you play in and these these parts well I
triumphed as one of the Von Trapp
daughters in The Sound of Music is that
really true are you having a Joe no I
promise you you played one of the Von
Trapp daughters yeah been really proud
you know I escaped from a prisoner of
war camp they should have just killed me
yeah
massive grants out in a white dress with
a blue satin sash did you did did your
grandpa and your in your parents come to
see these productions why did they send
you to an all-boys school what was that
that's just England and especially in
those days did you did you live at home
or did you like sleep online I lived at
home and the width thing was that for
various reasons my parents speak with
quite a posh voice English posh voice
and my school at that time was not at
all posh and I didn't even know I had
two voices
so when they'd come to watch me in as
Brigitta von trapp I would step out and
say a line night yeah hi my name's
Brigitta and all I want is a good time
how to complete London accent because
you wanted to fit in with the other boys
Yeah right
oh that's so funny and and were you in a
wig in a dress and there was a poor chap
who first he was older when they first
put him in a dress and it was quite a
clinging number and obviously it did
something for him and he stood there on
the stage and he got a hard-on if you
don't have a big entourage in a whole
business organisation how do I get you
for a film is it that I just send you do
I mail you a script is that it or as a
doral I do have an agent again now but I
did for four years not have one I told
everyone if you want me go to James
Howie Lee in London and he didn't exist
if it was me on a different email
account it's that right yeah so James
how really handled everything and these
people who are sending stuff they wanted
a personal relationship with James
they'd say we're coming to London next
week let's have lunch
did you ever call anyone as James Howe
Ely yeah I got rumbled in the end a car
number what happened but I gem had to
get on the phone one time what was
James's voice like well I was watching
the golf and there was a Scottish
commentator so I thought right he's
Scottish right and I did a pretty bad
Scottish accent like Michael I got a
little mr. Howe earlier how are you oh
that's right nice to see you nice to
hear from you how I
that's great to you as fast as I can now
did you feel guilty doing that I did a
bit yeah and then and then I start to
slip up because if I'd had a drink or
two right I'd write emails as James
Knight sign off Hugh
you